"Wir werden gebraucht, liebe Genossinnen und
Genossen.
Und mit diesem Selbstbewusstsein mischen wir
uns ein, werden wir Verantwortung übernehmen
in der Regierung, aber wir werden nicht verschwinden
in dieser Regierung.
Wir bleiben erkennbar.
Wir werden unsere eigenen politischen Punkte
machen und wir werden selbstbewusst Frau Merkel
die Stirn bieten.
Mit Verlaub Leute, sie mag ja die mächtigste
Frau der Welt sein, aber die Göttinnendämmerung
hat doch längst begonnen.
Warum sind wir denn so verzagt, da haben wir
gar keinen Grund für.
Frau Merkel ist doch eine, die angezählt
wird von ihrer eigenen Partei."